was hat das internet getan um ist bifie
das kann doch gar nicht sein oder ist
das alles nur ein fake die nächste stufe
der fake news tatsächlich sind heute
audiovisuelle lügen möglich die absolut
unglaublich sind täuschend echte videos
die zeigen wie menschen etwas tun was
sie gar nicht getan haben ist jetzt
opfer genau eines solchen die pigs
geworden obwohl opfer krieg zum science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
activity glocke nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
das war wirklich ein schock am
freitagnachmittag ein video machte die
runde
in dem der vegane ohne eine bifi ist war
das also all die jahre nur show und ohne
frönt weiterhin der fleischeslust oder
ist um hier opfer eines üblen streich
geworden
das werde ich hier im video aufklären
und zeigen wie diese unglaublichen
fälschungen möglich sind falschmeldungen
und zeitungsenten gibt es nämlich schon
seit es medien gibt mal reduziert die
sowjetunion politiker aus fotos mal ist
es einfach nur ein irrtum oder
staatliche oder politische propaganda
hat das ziel ein land zu destabilisieren
gegen dem feld ist das alles aber nur
kinderkram denn mit dem fake ist es
tatsächlich möglich heute noch mit
erheblichem aufwand in zukunft aber mit
einem mausklick videos zu fälschen
wie das geht hat marius angeschrien
jetzt in seinem aktuellen video gezeigt
den link findet ihr in dem video
beschreibung und am ende des videos zum
ersten mal sind solche die checks auf
reddit 2017 aufgetaucht damals gab es
plötzlich promi pornos ohne ende ohne
dass diese celebrity sehen nackt gefilmt
worden während ihm fakes wird das
verfahren genannt weil ihr die böning
eine form der künstlichen intelligenz
angewendet wird sie wertet die bilder
einer person aus und lernen sie so
kennen und dieses kennenlernen ist die
planning tiefes lernen oder tiefes
kennenlernen diesen ordner sind knapp
34.000 müller
7 und das jeden dieser bilder werden
jetzt quasi die gesicht da rauszuholen
jedes dieser bilder zeigt möglichst
einen anderen gesichtsausdruck marius
hat die gesichter dazu in vektoren
zerlegt um damit die gesichter von der
künstlichen intelligenz analysieren zu
lassen ein komplexes verfahren dass er
euch in seinem video ganz genau erklärt
leute wir haben jetzt drei uhr ein 50
ich habe jetzt erst mal 50.000 50.000
mal diesen bildern rhythmus laufen
lassen
das hat zu sechs stunden gedauert
schauen wir mal was passiert ich kann
schon müde aber so leicht ist es eben
nicht marius brauchte einige anläufe und
versuche bis das ergebnis dann so war
dass es wirklich täuschend echt aussah
und das ergebnis war dann wirklich schon
ziemlich beeindruckend mandat hat nie
vergessen
simon hat halt nie so geguckt dass
150.000 was jetzt die neue mit 20.000
das heißt ja richtig die abhilfe ich bin
mega wieder wenn wir vorzugreifen
jetzt ist der plan mit sturm waffel ein
video zu drehen indem er eine bifi ist
und das gesicht dann darauf zu legen
oder bei dem fake geht das halt etwas
anders es ist nicht nur ein programm um
videos zu verändern es ist eine ganz
ganz spezielles verfahren denn hierbei
zerlegt die künstliche intelligenz die
gesichter und baut sie wieder zusammen
ein bisschen so wie bei der musik
komprimierung der song wird
auseinandergenommen und codiert mit
deutlich weniger daten und dann bei uns
zu hause auf dem rechner oder dem
telefon wieder zusammengesetzt bei dem
fake ist das ähnlich beide gesichter
werden auseinander genommen dabei lernt
der algorithmus beiden gesichter und
deren ähnlichkeiten kennen beim video
wird dann allerdings beim zusammensetzen
des gesichtes der code ausgetauscht und
die in unserem fall das gesicht also der
code von sturm waffe gegen das gesicht
bzw denkt code von junge ausgetauscht
also als würde man in einem
komprimierten musikstück einfach die
gitarre gegen ein keyboard austauschen
das geht weil der algorithmus durch die
blühenden genau weiß wo das gesicht ist
und wie es aussehen müsste bams erklärt
das noch mal genauer aber das ist das
grund
fertig ist der fake danke für die
aufklärung marius und von hier aus auch
ein danke ansturm waffe rieso und
natürlich breaking lab dass ihr das
mitgemacht habt war natürlich alles
abgesprochen nämlich zu wissen dass man
auch mit videos komplett hinters licht
geführt werden kann
das ist extrem wichtig damit man solchen
fälschungen nicht auf den leim geht mehr
infos und die ganzen geschichte gibt es
natürlich hier bei marius im video der
uni bielefeld hat ohne wirklich fleisch
gegessen anklicken anschauen und marios
abonnieren das war für mich echt als
coolste experiment der letzten monate
bin gespannt was bei marius noch so
kommt bis dann bleibt dran